in this video we'll talk about the poly
a retro transposons
so let's first talk about
retrotransposons
retrotransposons are specific type of
transposons which can hop from one
location a to location B with the help
of RNA intermediate and in this process
it requires the help of reverse
transcription reaction and ultimately it
moves into a new location
retrotransposons amplify themselves
fairly quickly and that is why they are
very abundant in eukaryotic genome in
fact 49 of the Genome of maize is
consists of retrotransposons whereas 42
percent of the genome has
retrotransposons in humans
retrotransposons are of two major
categories one is LTR retrotransposons
which are very much like a retrovirus so
they are virus-like retrotransposons and
the another category that we are going
to talk about today is the non-ltr
retrotransposons and they are also known
as poly a retro transposons because they
have a polyethyl just like any
eukaryotic genes
so lines and signs these are the two
predominant form of poly a
retrotransposons line stands for long
interspersed nuclear element whereas
sine stands for short interspersed
nuclear element let me break it down for
you both lines and signs are short long
interspersed retro transposable elements
they can invade to new genomic site
using RNA intermediate now let me tell
you lines and signs are bit different
they are found in all the eukaryotes
almost like 34 percent of the eukaryotic
genomes lines and signs lines are
actually autonomous retro transposons
whereas signs are actually not
autonomous
for hopping from one location to another
location sign actually need the help of
lines
and they have difference in size lines
are bigger Mouse lines are actually six
thousand base pair whereas human signs
are only 248 base pairs smaller
now let us look at the overall structure
of the Retro transposon and they look
like Gene because they have a poly a
tail the five Prime and three prime utrs
are common between any eukaryotic Gene
and these polya Electro transposons
adjacent to the three prime utr most
striking thing is they have a 80 Rich
region which very much resembles the
polier tail of the eukaryotic mRNA
anyway the orif gives rise to two
important uh proteins
one is RNA binding protein another
encodes for endonuclease and reverse
transcriptase kind of enzyme
so lines encodes for these reverse
transcriptase enzyme which is used by
the signs to hop from one location to
another location that's why signs are
actually the dependent of lines
okay so let's talk about how lines and
signs are in general how
polyurethrotransposon can be integrated
into the genome what is the mechanism so
here is a line
so there are RNA polymerase that would
transcribe the line because it's it has
a promoter RNA polymerase can bind so
this is the five Prime utr three prime
utr polyethyl so this is a generic line
mRNA and this line MRNA would be
actually uh
actually be reverse transcribed with the
help of the orf2 products eventually
the protein bound to line goes to
particular tearish region in the DNA
so this target site is cleaved and uh
DNA RNA hybrid is formed as shown in
this image
then using this poly T there is a first
strand synthesis
eventually the second strand of the cdna
is synthesized and the DNA joining and
repairing happens and thereby a line
gets integrated into the eukaryotic
genome but there is a fun fact how does
eukaryotic how does these kind of like
um eukaryotic genome avoid the
possibility of incorporating any mRNA
into a random location because any mRNA
of any kind of structural gene looks
pretty similar to line mRNA and the
answer lies in these endonuclease and
reverse transcriptase kind of protein so
they are select they have selective
Affinity towards the line mRNA so they
preferably binds to the line mRNA and
Target them towards specific genomic
location but by mistake many of the
cases normal Gene sequences can also be
integrated into new locations and that
creates pseudogenes anyway this video
talks about the poly a retrotransposons
and their nature how they get integrated
into the genome
but wait a second what is the function
of these retrotransposon retrotransposon
can have many functions it can have
mutagenic effect imagine a transposon
Hopping into a particular Exon of a gene
and disrupting that open reading frame
so it could be mutagenic it can lead to
epigenetic silencing it can also act
like a source of long non-coding RNA
also it can work like an enhancer for a
given promoter so it have multiple uh
regulatory effects so I hope that was
useful
you can visit my Facebook page or
Instagram page for more such videos
support our Channel using super thanks
see you in next video
foreign